سلاح امريكي جديد لحسم المعارك في
اوكرانيا وبريطانيا تقدم اسرار اسلحتها
لروسيا على طبق من ذهب والولايات المتحده
خيار واحد امام زلناسك للخلاص او مواجهه
هزيمه شامله امام روسيا
وتحيطاني بشبه الجزيره الكوريه
وتستبيح الاجواء الروسيه فكيف سيرد بوتين
بان الاتحاد الاوروبي مديون لها بمليارات
اليوروهات وتخشى ان يكون قد انفقها على
اوكرانيا ومساعده قطريه لاوكرانيا باكثر
من مئه مليون دولار ماذا عن فلسطين وعشان
خطر عيون الاسرائيليين بايدن يرسل كبيره
مستشاريه الى السعوديه وكيم جونغ يستعرض
عضلاته النوويه ويعلن القتال الى جانب اي
دوله تع لن الغداء لامريكا
الرهان الاخير
اوكرانيا لم تعد مخيره بل مسيره وما بين
قوه موسكو المرعبه والدعم الغربي المهول
يتميز الجسد الاوكراني الايل للسقوط في
وحل الهزيمه لتعلنها مجله الامريكيه بانه
بعد فشل الهجوم المضاد بقي لدى الرئيس
الاوكراني
خيار واحد فقط للخلاص وهو المفاوضات مع
روسيا مع التنازل عن المطالبات بالاراضي
التي تسيطر عليها روسيا والا فسيواجه
هزيمه شامله امام الدب الروسي نعم يا ساده
فالغرب وعلى راسهم الامريكان يعلمون ان
اطاله مده الحرب لا تجلب سوى المزيد من
الخسائر الغربيه بمليارات الدولارات لدعم
اوكرانيا ولا شيء اخر وعلى ذكر المفاوضات
اعلن رئيس لجنه الشؤون الدوليه بمجلس
الدوم الروسي ليونس روتسكي ان المفاوضات
مع اوكرانيا مستحيله الان هذا ليس ذنب فقد
استغلت كييفا المفاوضات في وقت سابق لكسب
الوقت وفق قوله ومن جانبه قال رئيس
الوزراء هنغاريا ان استمرار وجود اوكرانيا
وقدره القوات الاوكرانيه على القتال
يعتمدان فقط على ثلاثه اشياء وهي المال ثم
المال والمال وفق تعبيره ويقصد اموال
الدول الغربيه مشددا على ان اوكرانيا فقدت
سيادتها كدوله ليطلقها اوربا صريحه هذه
المره في وجه الاتحاد الاوروبي في قوله ان
الاتحاد مديون لهنغاريا بمليارات
وتخشى بودابست انه قد تم انفاق هذه
الاموال على اوكرانيا لكن يبدو ان واشنطن
لا تكل ولا تمل من ارفاد بالمزيد من الدعم
وهنا افادت صحيفه بوليتيك وان الولايات
المتحده تتوقع تسليم دبابات ايبرونزي الى
اوكرانيا في سبتمبر المقبل التي تامل ان
تساعدها بشكل
[موسيقى]
ما اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قوتها
صدت كل الهجمات التي شنها الجيش الاوكراني
على خطوط التماس وان خسائر العدو اليوميه
بلغت حوالي 6090 جنديا والعهده على المصدر
فكل هذه الارقام اليوميه ينشرها الموقع
الرسمي للحكومه الروسيه كما تشاهدون
امامكم في المقابل اعلن الرئيس الاوكراني
استعاده قريه
بجنوب شرقي البلاد من القوات الروسيه
وقالت نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان
العسكريين يواصلون تطير القريه من الالغام
المعارك لا تنتهي والهجمات لا تتوقف وهنا
تواصل كييف استثاره غضب الدب الروسي
بمهاجمه عاقله حيث عادت الدفاع الروسيه
تدمير مسيره اوكرانيه كانت تحاول مهاجمه
منشاه في مقاطعه موسكو بينما اعلنت
السلطات الروسيه ان 15 شخصا اصيب بجروح
بعد سقوط شظايا صاروخ اطلقت القوات
الاوكرانيه على مدينه تاجان روج الحدوديه
الجنوبيه روسيا اذا برايكم هل تعدوا
مهاجمتكيف للاراضي الروسيه شجاعه اوكرانيه
اما التقارير الغربيه فتقول ان هذه
الهجمات الاوكرانيه هي تغطيه على فشل
الهجوم المضاد فهل هي كذلك وبين كل هذه
الهجمات والضربات والخسائر خرجت للعيان
مبادره افريقيه لحل هذه الحرب من جذورها
ليصرح رئيس الاتحاد الافريقي ورئيس جزر
القمر غزال عثماني اظهر لنا الرئيس بوتين
استعداده للدخول في حوار وايجاد حل والان
نحن بحاجه الى اقناع الجانب الاخر امل ان
ننجح ونحن كذلك يا هذا لتتجه بنا بوصله
الاحداث نحو بريطانيا حيث كشفت صحيفه
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه وبسبب خط في
عنوان البريد الالكتروني ارسلت رسائل
تحتوي على معلومات سريه الى مالي حالي في
روسيا الوثيق وقالت الصحيفه ان الرسائل
احتوت على معلومات مفصله عن ابحاث
بريطانيه في مجال الصواريخ الفائقه السرعه
يا لها من هديه ثمينه ومفاجئه لبوتين وكما
يقولها المثل اليمني هي رزاق مشي على
البكاره اي ان الرزق سياتيك حتى وانصحوا
من نومك متاخرا ومن البر الى احشاء البحار
والمحيطات حيث اكدت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
بدا سفن بحريه الروسيه والبحريه الصينيه
تسير دوريات بحريه مشتركه في المحيط
الهادئ بعد تحرك سفن البحريه الروسيه
والبحريه الصينيه من بلادي فستوك الروسيه
القريبه من شبه الجزيره الكوريه وذلك
لتامين المنطقه ومراقبتها وفق بيان
الوزاره الرو
الاحداث والتطورات
افادت وكاله السوشيال بان الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن او فدا كبيره مستشاريه الى
السعوديه لاجراء محادثات مع ولي العهد
محمد بن سلمان بشان تطبيع العلاقات مع
اسرائيل فهل تقبل قبله المسلمين الاولى
بخذلان القبله الثانيه كشفت كوريا
الشماليه عن مسيرات جديده وصواريخ
باليستيه عابره للقارات ذات قدرات نوويه
خلال استعراض عسكري لاحياء الذكرى السبعين
لانتهاء الحرب في شبه الجزيره الكوريه
ووفقا لما اوردته وكاله رويترز والتي نقلت
تاكيدها انها ستقاتل الى جانب الدول التي
تواجه ما سمتها الهيمنه الامريكيه حذر
قائد القوات الجويه في اسرائيل من وجود
تهديد امني وان من وصفهم باعداء تل ابيب
يمكن ان يستغلوا الازمه الحاليه واوضح
اخبار ان الاحتجاجات الح اليه على
التعديلات القضائيه تنعكس على الجبهه
الداخليه الغرب يعلمون في قراره انفسهم ان
اوكرانيا لا تستطيع مجابات الدب الروسي
ولكن لا يريدون الاعتراف بالهزيمه رايكم
هل اقتربت تلك الهزيمه
[موسيقى]